foreign
[Music]
West and Kris Jenner show love for
Tristan Thompson Courtside that's what
we do the famous fam hit up the Los
Angeles Lakers game against the Memphis
Grizzlies on Monday night where they
cheered for Chloe's on-again off-again
Beau who was recently traded to the LA
team Kim's plus one her seven-year-old
son Saint who rocked a jersey with
Tristan's new number on it and naturally
the two posed it up for a few Game Day
selfies you just gotta roll with it as
for Chris she came with boyfriend Corey
Gamble and at one point during the game
Tristan came over and gave the famous
momager a big hug it's never a dull
moment but the Kardashian Jenners
weren't the only celebs at the game Adam
Sandler Sean Diddy Combs record exec
Jimmy iveen Timothy Oliphant and flee
from the Red Hot Chili Peppers or were
also there to watch the Lakers beat the
Grizzlies
117-11 oh and let's not forget this
Royal sighting Meghan Markle and Prince
Harry who made a cameo on the Jumbotron
I don't know what's gonna top that but
back to Tristan and Chloe the NBA Pro is
the dad of Coco's two kiddos
five-year-old daughter true and an
almost nine-month-old son whose name has
not been revealed he's named but I
haven't announced it you haven't
announced it I haven't announced it yet
fans have been speculating about the
status of Chloe and Tristan's
relationship after she liked this post
from the LA Lakers earlier this month
announcing the news of his trade to the
team I'm someone who I do like to put my
relationships as a priority and I tried
to make I really try to make that work
but also I think keeping it a little
private too has really helped us the two
called it quits in December 2021 while
they were secretly engaged the good
American founder previously claimed that
Kristen encouraged her to do an embryo
transfer to have another child via
surrogate just days before news broke
that he'd fathered a child with another
woman while he and Chloe were together
we did an embryo transfer like days
before Thanksgiving and I found out
about Tristan's situation the first week
of December I was definitely very angry
and I think
feeling
Bamboozled a source recently told ET
that the NBA star still loves Chloe
would love to be with her again and is
doing whatever he can to try to prove
himself to his ex and her family but the
two are not together she chooses to be
supportive both publicly and privately
for the sake of their children everyone
has to handle their co-parenting
situation in their own style it's hard
work for all parties it's a beautiful
thing to get along with each other and
for your kids to see that now we'll just
have to wait and see how Chloe and
Tristan's relationship plays out on
season three of the family's Hulu series
when it premieres in May I wish I could
tell you this is going to be a mild
relaxing Serene season
it's not